This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2008, a billion gallons of toxic sludge spewed across 300 acres of Tennessee in the middle of the night. It was just before Christmas. I was a senior in high school and I remember seeing this billion gallons of sludge covering this town outside of Knoxville and thinking, wow, that looks awful. That's Jared Sullivan. For over 50 years, a power company called the Tennessee Valley Authority, or TVA, had been burning coal at a power plant near Jared's hometown. Burning all that coal helped bring electricity to the region, but it also created a mountain of ash and waste. Over the years, this mountain grew to be 60 feet high and 84 acres wide. And on December 22, 2008, the earthen embankment that contained this mountain of waste collapsed.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。2008年，在田纳西州的一个深夜，十亿加仑的有毒污泥倾泻而出，覆盖了300英亩的土地。那时正值圣诞节前夕。我当时是一名高中生，我记得看到这十亿加仑的污泥覆盖了诺克斯维尔郊外的那座城镇，心想，哇，那看起来太可怕了。那是贾里德·沙利文。50多年来，一家名为田纳西河谷管理局（简称TVA）的电力公司一直在贾里德家乡附近的一座发电厂燃烧煤炭。燃烧这些煤炭为该地区带来了电力，但也堆积起了一座由灰烬和废料组成的山。多年来，这座山长到了60英尺高，占地84英亩。2008年12月22日，围住这座废料山的土堤坍塌了。
A lethal wave of coal sludge inundated the countryside. If you pull up the footage and look it up on YouTube or whatever, it really sticks with you because it is biblical in scope what happened. This disaster came to be known as the Kingston coal ash spill, and the culprit wasn't a private company. It was the TVA, a federally owned electricity provider that had been set up by the government during the New Deal. Immediately after this happened, TVA's PR lackeys got on the news and basically said, this stuff isn't toxic, no big deal, don't worry about it. And 900 blue collar workers from around the country descended on the site to help clean
一股致命的煤泥浪潮淹没了乡村。如果你在YouTube或其他地方搜索相关视频，那场面真的会让你难以忘怀，因为所发生的一切规模之大简直如同圣经中的灾难。这场灾难后来被称为金斯顿煤灰泄漏事件，而罪魁祸首并非一家私营公司。它是TVA，一家由政府在“新政”时期建立的联邦电力供应商。事件发生后，TVA的公关走狗立即出现在新闻中，基本上说，这些东西没有毒，没什么大不了的，不用担心。随后，来自全国各地的900名蓝领工人涌向现场进行清理。
it up. Everyone expected that they'd find bodies under the sludge. It was a miracle that no one died that night. The real tragedy came years later, when many of the workers in charge of the cleanup fell sick and even died from health issues caused by inhaling the toxins found in coal ash. The fallout from what happened at the Kingston coal plant led Jared to look more closely at the company in charge, the Tennessee Valley Authority. The TVA has been around since the 1930s, and today it provides electricity
每个人都以为他们会在污泥下发现尸体。那天晚上没有人死亡简直是个奇迹。真正的悲剧发生在多年后，当时许多负责清理工作的工人生病，甚至因吸入煤灰中的毒素而导致健康问题死亡。金斯顿煤电厂事件的后果促使贾里德更仔细地审视了负责的公司——田纳西河谷管理局。TVA自20世纪30年代以来一直存在，如今它为超过1000万人提供电力。
to more than 10 million people. Its presence in the Southeast had a huge impact in transforming the region. The TVA is a backdrop to life as portrayed in Southern literature, film, and music. It's part of the region's folklore. So I thank God for the TVA. So I thank God for the TVA. Thank God for the TVA.
它在东南部的存在对改变该地区产生了巨大影响。TVA是南方文学、电影和音乐中所描绘的生活背景。它是该地区民间传说的一部分。所以我感谢上帝赐予我们TVA。所以我感谢上帝赐予我们TVA。感谢上帝赐予我们TVA。
Where, oh, so they'll let us all work for an honest day's pay. I grew up in Tennessee and everyone's kind of vaguely familiar with TVA, but I did not really know the full history of what TVA was until I started reporting and writing this book. Jared writes about the TVA in his new book, Valley So Low. One Lawyer's Fight for Justice in the Wake of America's Great Coal Catastrophe. It's hard to remember those long subtitles. I had to...
噢，他们会让我们所有人都能靠诚实的劳动获得报酬。我在田纳西州长大，每个人对TVA都略知一二，但在我开始报道并撰写这本书之前，我并不真正了解TVA的全部历史。贾里德在他的新书《低谷：美国大煤炭灾难后一位律师的正义之战》中写到了TVA。那些长长的副标题很难记住。我不得不……
I know. You see me side-eyeing my book. I was like, what's my book called again? Jared's book follows the aftermath of the disaster at the Kingston coal plant. And in doing so, his book reveals an even larger, ongoing American tragedy. How the TVA started out as a mission-driven public institution, but ended up acting like a private for-profit company. And what that shift can tell us about the consequences of privatization. The story of TVA really begins in many respects
我知道。你看到我斜眼看我的书了。我当时在想，我的书叫什么来着？贾里德的书追踪了金斯顿煤电厂灾难的后果。通过这样做，他的书揭示了一个更大、正在发生的美国悲剧。TVA是如何从一个使命驱动的公共机构开始，最终却表现得像一家营利性私营公司的。这种转变能告诉我们关于私有化后果的什么信息。TVA的故事在许多方面其实始于……
with Franklin Roosevelt, who, as a young man, contracted polio and began making trips to Warm Springs, Georgia, for treatment. And on those trips, he got a firsthand look at how dire the situation was in the Tennessee Valley. During the 1920s, the Tennessee Valley, which is an area covering nearly all of Tennessee, large chunks of Alabama, Mississippi, and Kentucky, and bits of three other states, was deeply impoverished.
富兰克林·罗斯福，他年轻时患上了小儿麻痹症，并开始前往佐治亚州的沃姆斯普林斯接受治疗。在这些旅途中，他亲眼目睹了田纳西河谷的情况有多么糟糕。在20世纪20年代，田纳西河谷——一个覆盖了几乎整个田纳西州、阿拉巴马州、密西西比州和肯塔基州的大部分地区，以及其他三个州部分地区的区域——极度贫困。
Much of the valley was farmland, but only 3% of these farms had electricity. The area also had a per capita income of less than half of the national average, and about a third of the population was stricken with malaria. The poverty was so crushing that it really challenged the notion of whether a democracy could care for its people and whether the American experiment had vitality. On the farms, crops would suffer from an uneven climate. Constant flooding from the Tennessee River would badly damage the soil. Sometimes the outlook was so bleak that people would abandon their farms altogether.
河谷的大部分地区是农田，但只有3%的农场有电。该地区的人均收入不到全国平均水平的一半，约三分之一的人口患有疟疾。贫困程度之深，以至于它真正挑战了民主制度能否照顾其人民以及美国实验是否具有活力的观念。在农场里，作物会因气候不均而受损。田纳西河不断的洪水会严重破坏土壤。有时前景如此黯淡，以至于人们会完全放弃他们的农场。
In the mountains, families lived in very crude, rudimentary shacks. They slept, in many cases, multiple people in a bed to stay warm throughout the winter. Infant mortality rates were high. People caught typhoid from drinking bad water, malaria was endemic. It was a grave, grave situation. There was this notion that something needed to be done, if not simply for the good of the people, then at least to prevent some sort of uprising.
在山区，家庭住在非常简陋的棚屋里。在许多情况下，他们几个人睡在一张床上以在整个冬天保持温暖。婴儿死亡率很高。人们因饮用受污染的水而感染伤寒，疟疾是地方性流行病。这是一个非常、非常严峻的局面。当时有一种观念认为必须采取行动，如果不是单纯为了人民的利益，至少也要防止某种起义。
There's actually some concern that the Southeast was ripe for a populist uprising, because the system was so not working, because the Bolshevik Revolution had not been that many years in the past, right? So there was really a strong sense of like, we have to do something or this region may never catch up or worse. The idea was simple.
实际上有人担心东南部已经成熟，随时可能爆发民粹主义起义，因为体制完全失效了，而且布尔什维克革命发生的时间并不久，对吧？所以当时有一种强烈的紧迫感，觉得我们必须做点什么，否则这个地区可能永远无法赶上，甚至更糟。这个想法很简单。
Electric power should become a public good, because if you want to improve people's lives, you have to give them electricity. The problem was at the time that all the big power companies were owned by private holding companies and there was no financial incentive for them to provide power to rural areas because there were just not that many people out there. There was not that much money to make from these rural communities. But as a result, these communities were basically stuck. Then in 1933, FDR got sworn in as president and pretty quickly got to work on New Deal programs,
电力应该成为一种公共产品，因为如果你想改善人们的生活，你就必须给他们提供电力。当时的问题是，所有的大型电力公司都由私人控股公司拥有，他们没有经济动力为农村地区提供电力，因为那里的人口并不多。从这些农村社区赚不到多少钱。但结果是，这些社区基本上被困住了。然后在1933年，罗斯福宣誓就任总统，并很快开始着手实施“新政”计划，
one of which was to establish a power company, the Tennessee Valley Authority. In 1933, we started. Down on the Tennessee River, when Congress created the Tennessee Valley Authority, an authority commissioned to develop navigation, flood control, agriculture, and industry in the valley. It was, for almost a quarter century, the single most ambitious public work project in the world. Its mission was to lift the rural South out of poverty by making electricity more accessible to all. TVA had three basic goals.
其中之一就是建立一家电力公司，即田纳西河谷管理局。1933年，我们开始了。在田纳西河上，当国会创建田纳西河谷管理局时，这是一个受命开发河谷航运、防洪、农业和工业的机构。在近四分之一个世纪里，它是世界上最雄心勃勃的公共工程项目。其使命是通过让所有人都能更方便地用电，将农村南方从贫困中拉出来。TVA有三个基本目标。
Control the Tennessee River, produce power, and improve agriculture. The Tennessee River's propensity to flood not only damaged farmland, but also sometimes took out entire towns. It wiped out the city of Chattanooga, and I believe it was the 1870s, almost completely drowned the whole city. So they needed to control the amount of water that was coming down the Tennessee River, because you can't develop as a society
控制田纳西河，生产电力，改善农业。田纳西河的洪水倾向不仅破坏了农田，有时还会摧毁整个城镇。它摧毁了查塔努加市，我相信是在19世纪70年代，几乎完全淹没了整个城市。所以他们需要控制流经田纳西河的水量，因为如果你的城市每隔十几年就被冲走一次，你就无法发展，对吧？目标是控制河流并产生水力发电，于是大坝的建设开始了。他们利用征用权从家园中搬迁了约2万个家庭，并在他们的位置上，在河谷中点缀了大坝
if your city's getting washed away every dozen years or so, right? The goal was to control the river and generate hydroelectric power, and so began the construction of the dams. They used eminent domain to remove about 20,000 families from their homesteads, and in their place, they peppered the valley with dams
和粗野主义风格的混凝土建筑。1933年《TVA法案》通过后不久，TVA匆忙开始在整个田纳西河谷建造水力发电大坝。他们从头到尾独立完成的第一座大坝是诺克斯维尔郊外的诺里斯大坝。首先是大坝。在河流上游的克林奇河上。我们建造了诺里斯大坝，这是一道在洪水时期蓄水的巨大屏障，
and brutalist concrete buildings. Shortly after the TVA Act of 1933 is passed, TVA rushes to start building hydroelectric dams throughout the Tennessee Valley. And the first one that they complete themselves from start to finish is Norris Dam outside of Knoxville. First came the dams. Up on the clench at the head of the river. We built Norristown a great barrier to hold water in flood time
并在枯水期向下游放水以供航运。这是大萧条时期，人们需要工作，所以他们雇佣了4万名男子在整个田纳西河上建造这些大坝，最终他们总共建造了49座大坝，其中29座用于发电。这有助于控制河流，并有助于在南方产生急需的电力。它确实奏效了。但TVA并没有止步于建造大坝。TVA最初还有许多其他类似乌托邦式的副项目。
And to release water down the river for navigation in low water This is the middle of the Great Depression people needed jobs So they hired 40,000 men to throw up these dams all up the Tennessee River and they end up building It was 49 dams in all 29 of which produce power So that helped control the river and it helped generate much-needed electricity in the south. And it really worked. But the TVA didn't stop at just building dams. TVA initially had all these other like utopian side projects.
很难想象今天的联邦政府还会做这样的事情。它有一个移动图书馆服务，向人们借出了数万本书。它创办了一个陶瓷实验室。它创建了13000个示范农场，教当地人如何最大限度地提高作物产量。在TVA于1933年建造第一座大坝的同时，他们还建立了一个名为诺里斯的城镇。诺里斯的建立是为了安置建造附近大坝的工人。但这个城镇也是向美国展示合作生活方式如何
It's hard to imagine the federal government ever doing something like this today. It had a mobile library service that loaned out tens of thousands of books to people. It started a ceramics laboratory. It created 13,000 demonstration farms where it taught locals how to maximize crop yields. Alongside TVA's construction of their first dam in 1933, they also established a town called Norris. Norris was created to house the workers building the nearby dam. But the town was also a way to show America how cooperative living could
运作的一种方式。诺里斯完全适合步行，大多数房屋彼此相对而不是面向街道。它包括一个绿化带、一所供大坝工人上课的学校、一个邮局、一个健身房，甚至还有一个农贸市场。TVA的一些董事实际上就住在这个小小的规划社区里。它非常可爱。直到今天它仍然存在。在最初的几年里，TVA继续稳步建造越来越多的水坝。在此过程中，他们成为了美国最大的电力生产商。
work. Norris was completely walkable with most homes facing each other instead of the street. It included a greenbelt, a school where dam workers could take classes, a post office, a gym, and even a farmer's market. And TVA, some of their board directors actually live in this little playing community. It's very cute. It still exists to this day. In those first few years, TVA continued to steadily build more and more dams. And in the process, they became the largest producer of electric power in the United States.
但这些大规模的政府干预也伴随着很多阻力。关于输电线路的争论非常激烈，私营工业绝对抵制TVA。他们非常担心TVA会扩张到他们的领地。一个名叫温德尔·威尔基的人领导了反对TVA的斗争。他是南方一家大型私营电力公司的总裁。温德尔和其他电力公司代表对他们所认为的不公平竞争感到痛苦。他们将TVA告上了最高法院，并两次败诉。TVA有让南方电气化的宏伟抱负。它做到了。大坝驯服了
But these massive government interventions came with a lot of pushback. It was a huge fight over transmission lines and private industry definitely pushed back on TVA. They were very scared that TVA was going to expand into their territory. A guy named Wendell Wilkie led the fight against the TVA. He was the president of a large private power company in the South. Wendell and other power company reps complained bitterly about what they saw as unfair competition. They took the TVA to the Supreme Court and lost, twice. The TVA had this grand ambition to electrify the South. And it did. The dams tamed the
河流并控制了洪水，这意味着更健康的土壤和更高产的农田。水力发电便宜且易得，这意味着生活水平显著提高。对于那些受益者来说，这是一场社会革命。它雄心勃勃，意图高尚，而且确实奏效了。我真的觉得这就像一个美国奇迹。它体现了政府的良好作为。
rivers and controlled the floods, which meant healthier soil and more productive farmland. Hydroelectric power was cheap and available, which meant the standard of living increased dramatically. For those who benefited, it was a social revolution. It was ambitious and had noble intentions and it actually worked. And I really do feel like it is like an American miracle. It exemplified a good government inaction.
田纳西河谷第一次在天黑后被照亮。在全国最保守的地区之一，数百万人从一个没有股东需要负责、也没有利润可赚的联邦机构获得了电力。然后发生了一件事，导致TVA突然改变了方向。永远改变TVA的大事是第二次世界大战。在二战期间，TVA提供了全国国防工业所用电力的十分之一。
For the first time ever, the Tennessee Valley could be lit up after dark. In one of the most conservative regions in the country, millions of people got their electricity from a federal agency that had no shareholders to answer to and no profits to make. And then something happened that caused the TVA to suddenly change direction. The big thing that forever changed TVA was World War II. During World War II, TVA supplied a tenth of all the electricity used by the country's defense industries.
TVA这个联邦政府的项目，突然被征召来支持战争。生产武器和军事装备以及制造原子弹都需要电力。政府决定将曼哈顿计划设在田纳西州的橡树岭，正是因为TVA。然而，这一切意味着，原本流向公众的电力现在被挪用到了战争中。然后在20世纪40年代初，国会担心电力短缺，因为它预测会有一个干旱年份，这将降低整个河谷的河流水位。
The TVA, which was a program of the federal government, was suddenly summoned to support the war. Electricity was needed to produce weapons and military equipment, and to build atomic bombs. The government decided to base the Manhattan Project in Oak Ridge, Tennessee because of TVA. What all this meant, though, was that electricity that was previously going to the public was now being siphoned off for war. Then in the early 1940s, Congress feared a power shortage because it was forecasting a dry year, which would lower the river levels throughout the valley.
第二年，在政府的敦促和资助下，TVA开始建造其第一座燃煤发电厂。这意味着TVA的部分电力将不再依赖天气。二战后，田纳西州继续从事炸弹制造业务。这一次，冷战核武库需要浓缩铀。因此，对TVA电力的需求持续上升。
The following year, at the government's urging and with its funding, the TVA began construction on its first coal-fired power plant. It meant that at least some of the TVA's power would no longer depend on the weather. After World War II, Tennessee stayed in the bomb-making business. This time, there was a need for uranium enrichment for the Cold War nuclear arsenal. And so, the demand for TVA's electricity kept going up.
此后就是冷战。广岛事件后，橡树岭并没有关闭，对吧？恰恰相反。橡树岭仍然在从事炸弹制造，TVA必须为其提供电力。在某一时期，它近一半的电力流向了橡树岭的政府炸弹制造设施。与此同时，南方的人口也在增加。空调变得更加普及，所以住在这里变得更加可以忍受。
After that, it was the Cold War. Oak Ridge did not shut down after Hiroshima, right? Just the opposite. Oak Ridge is still in the bomb making game and TVA had to supply power for it. Almost half its power at one point went to the government bomb making facilities in Oak Ridge. Meanwhile, the South was also seeing an uptick in population. AC became more widely available, air conditioning, so it was like more tolerable to live here.
因此，许多人向南迁移。TVA的电力生产无法跟上战争制造商和居住在河谷的人们日益增长的需求。所以他们开始建造更多的燃煤电厂。他们最终建造了11座世界上最大的燃煤电厂。部分是为了服务橡树岭，但同样也是为了
So a lot of people migrated south. And TVA's power production couldn't keep up with the growing demand from both war manufacturers and people living in the Valley. So they started to build more coal power plants. And they ended up building 11 of the world's largest coal fire power plants. Partially to serve Oak Ridge, but also again,
满足这里不断增长的人口的能源需求。煤电厂便宜且有助于利润。在如此大的压力下，这是生产更多电力的最简单方法。然后在1952年，德怀特·艾森豪威尔当选总统，与罗斯福不同，他对整个TVA持高度怀疑态度。他非常讨厌TVA。他指责这是“渐进式社会主义”的一个例子，据报道他想把整个机构卖掉。
to meet the energy demands from the growing population here. Coal plants were cheap and helped the bottom line. It was the easiest way to produce more power under so much pressure. Then in 1952, Dwight Eisenhower was elected president, and unlike FDR, he was highly skeptical of TVA as a whole. He really hated TVA. He accused that being an example of, quote, creeping socialism, and he reportedly wanted to sell off the whole thing.
艾森豪威尔政府影响了TVA的扩张能力，尽管比以往任何时候都有更多的人需要电力。与艾森豪威尔结盟的国会共和党人反复扣留了TVA的拨款，而TVA需要这些拨款来建造发电厂以跟上能源需求。然后在1959年，艾森豪威尔完全切断了TVA的联邦资金。
Eisenhower's administration affected TVA's ability to expand, even though more people were in need of electricity than ever before. Republicans in Congress who are aligned with Eisenhower, they repeatedly withheld appropriations from TVA, which it needed to build power plants to keep up with energy demand. Then in 1959, Eisenhower cut TV off from federal funding entirely.
这是一个巨大的变化。这意味着TVA虽然由政府拥有，但为了筹集资金，必须开始像私营公司一样运作。自1959年以来，TVA通过发行和出售债券为其电力项目筹集资金。这种新的财务模式意味着TVA开始改变其优先事项。曾经是罗斯福旨在将东南部从贫困中拉出来的使命驱动型项目，其重点转移到了
This was a monumental change. It meant that the TVA, although owned by the government, needed to start operating like a private corporation in order to finance itself. Since 1959, the TVA has raised capital for its electricity projects by issuing and selling bonds. This new financial model meant that the TVA began to shift its priorities. What was once FDR's mission-driven project to lift up the Southeast from poverty shifted its focus to
创造利润上。再也没有时间和金钱去搞那些可爱的、适合步行的小镇，去教人们如何耕种和制作陶瓷了。在TVA历史的这一新篇章中，这些社会服务首先被抛弃了。证明其他项目的合理性变得不可能。证明农场项目、甚至陶瓷实验室、图书馆等项目的合理性变得不可能。所有这些似乎都……它只是被抛弃了，因为TVA现在必须如此专注于金钱，并实际上表现得更像一家公司，对吧？我认为这是TVA从准政府公司转变为
building profit. There was no time or money anymore for cute little walkable towns where you learn how to farm and do ceramics. In this new chapter in TVA history, those social services were the first to fall away. It was impossible to justify the other programs. It was impossible to justify the farm programs, even things like the ceramics laboratory, the library. All of that just seemed, it was impossible to justify the farm programs, even things like the ceramics laboratory, the library, all of that just seemed, it just fell by the wayside because TVA had to be so focused on money now and actually act more like a corporation, right? I think this is the period where TVA went from being this quasi-governmental corporation
基本上是一家彻头彻尾的公司的时期。它演变成了一个电力巨头，因为它必须像以前从未有过的那样真正关心金钱。随着时间的推移，TVA开始大量输出电力，在整个河谷生产大量的燃煤电力。然后他们开始策划向核能转型。
to basically a true and true corporation. And it morphed into a power giant because it had to really care about money, unlike it had before. Over time, the TVA began pumping out electricity, producing large quantities of coal-powered electricity throughout the valley. Then they started plotting a transition to nuclear power.
在60年代末，政府开始通过第一波大型环境法。TVA感受到了压力。因此，他们决定建造七座巨型核电站，拥有17个核反应堆。1965年，TVA宣布了其第一座核电站的计划。诺克斯维尔的一份报纸头条写道：“核能在金煤电厂咆哮”。但从一开始，这几乎就是一场灾难。
In the late 60s, the government starts passing this first big wave of environmental laws. And TVA feels the pressure of this. So they decide that it's going to build seven jumbo nuclear power plants with 17 nuclear reactors. In 1965, the TVA announced plans for its first nuclear plant. A Knoxville newspaper headline read, nuclear roars at King Cole. But it's almost a disaster right from the beginning.
有充分记录显示，TVA的核项目进度严重滞后，预算严重超支，并且多次被完全放弃。在TVA计划建造的七座核电站中，只有三座完工。在TVA因核能事业背负了100亿美元债务后，建造其余核电站的计划便不了了之。
There's a well-documented record of TVA's nuclear projects running far behind schedule, far over budget, and many times being abandoned altogether. Of the seven nuclear power plants TVA had intended to build, only three of them were completed. Plans to build the rest fell away after the TVA amassed $10 billion in debt because of their nuclear endeavors.
然后在1975年，TVA在阿拉巴马州布朗斯费里的第一座核电站意外起火。有一名电工在寻找管道里的漏气，他用点燃的火柴来寻找漏气点。我不是电工，我不会假装理解点燃的火柴如何能帮你找到管道里的漏气，
And then in 1975, TVA's first nuclear plant in Browns Ferry, Alabama, accidentally caught on fire. There was an electrician looking for an air leak like in a pipe or something, and he's using a lit match to find the air leaks. I'm not an electrician looking for an air leak, like in a pipe or something, and he's using a lit match to find the air leaks. I'm not an electrician, I won't pretend to understand how a lit match will help you find an air leak in a pipe,
但它点燃了整个巨大的区域，迫使工厂紧急停工，并造成了数百万美元的损失。所以这是最值得注意的安全问题，但还有无数其他小问题。尽管核能比煤炭更清洁，但实施成本要高得多。TVA没有资金真正投资于这个实验。其最初的核能失败，加上三哩岛等其他众所周知的核灾难，
but it catches this whole huge area on fire and it forces an emergency shutdown at the plant and causes millions of dollars of damages. So that's like the most noteworthy safety issue, but there was tons of other small issues. Even though nuclear power is cleaner than coal, it's a lot more expensive to implement. The TVA didn't have the money to really invest in this experiment. And its initial nuclear failures, along with other well-known nuclear disasters like Three Mile Island,
阻碍了公众对核能转向更清洁能源潜力的看法。在整个20世纪80年代，TVA取消或搁置了许多这些核项目。有些今天只存在于蓝图中，而另一些则是点缀在田纳西河谷景观中的混凝土和金属碎片。核能惨败给TVA留下了近200亿美元的总债务。所有这一切也意味着TVA仍然严重依赖煤炭来生产电力。所以TVA想摆脱煤炭，但就是做不到。它实际上仍然沉迷于煤炭，并且在接下来的几十年里都将如此。
mired public perception of nuclear power's potential to pivot to cleaner energy. Throughout the 1980s, the TVA cancelled or put on hold many of these nuclear projects. Some exist today only as blueprints, while others are fragments of concrete and metal that dot the landscape of the Tennessee Valley. The nuclear fiasco has left TVA with a total debt of nearly $20 billion. All of this also meant that the TVA was still heavily relying on coal to produce its power. So TVA wanted to get off coal, it just couldn't. But it was still effectively hooked on coal and would be for the next several decades.
这正是我的书开始的地方。这是在TVA燃烧煤炭几十年却无法摆脱之后。休息之后，我将与贾里德讨论TVA坚持使用煤炭的后果之一，即田纳西州金斯顿煤电厂那十亿加仑的有毒污泥喷发。我回到了贾里德·沙利文身边。所以你的书主要集中在TVA运营的一家特定燃煤电厂上。它是田纳西州金斯顿的金斯顿化石燃料电厂。
And that is really where my book picks up. It's after decades of TVA burning coal and not being able to get off of it. After the break, I talk with Jared about one of the consequences of TVA's decision to stick with coal, that billion gallon toxic sludge eruption at the Kingston Coal Plant in Tennessee. I'm back with Jared Sullivan. So your book largely centers on one particular coal power plant that's run by TVA. It's the Kingston Fossil Plant in Kingston, Tennessee.
跟我说说这个电厂。金斯顿化石燃料电厂建于1954年，或者说它在1954年首次上线。它产生的电力足以供70万户家庭使用。它是一个巨大的设施，坐落在两条河流——克林奇河和埃默里河的交汇处。
Tell me about this plant. The Kingston Fossil Plant was built in 1954, or rather it went online for the first time in 1954. It creates enough electricity to power 700,000 homes. It is a jumbo jumbo facility, and it sits at the confluence of two rivers, the Clinch and the Emory.
所以在2008年，十亿加仑这种被称为煤灰的物质从这个发电厂喷涌而出。什么是煤灰？煤灰有点像……它是你燃烧煤炭发电后剩下的东西。这几乎就像如果你有一个木炭烧烤架，它是之后剩下的煤灰，比如在底部的那种。那么煤电厂运营商在管理或处置这种煤灰方面的典型系统或协议是什么？
And so in 2008, a billion gallons of this substance called coal ash bursts out of this power plant. What is coal ash? Coal ash is kind of this, it's like the stuff that's left over after you burn coal to produce electricity. It's almost like if you have like a charcoal barbecue, it's like the sooty stuff that's left over afterwards, like in the bottom of it. So what has been the typical system or protocol that coal power plant operators use in terms of managing or disposing of this coal ash?
每家电力公司（不仅仅是TVA）的标准做法就是挖一个大坑，把所有的煤灰倒在那里。他们称之为池塘，这个煤灰池塘，但这个名字并不准确。它不是一个池塘。这东西实际上长成了一座山。它有六层楼高，占地84英亩。我应该说，全国有750个这样的东西。这不仅仅是TVA的问题。
The standard practice for every power company, not just TVA, was just to dig a big hole in the ground and dump all your coal ash there. They call it a pond, this coal ash pond, but the name is not accurate. It's not a pond. This thing grows into a mountain effectively. It's six stories tall and 84 acres. These I should say, there's 750 of these things across the country. This is not just a TVA problem.
而且几乎所有这些池塘都会将毒素泄漏到地下水中。它们是一个巨大的、巨大的烂摊子。在金斯顿，这座煤灰山只是发电厂附近景观的一部分。TVA用一层粘土覆盖了它，这使得草可以在上面生长。所以对于不熟悉的人来说，它看起来可能就像一座长满草的小山。人们会在这座土堆上进行日常的晨跑。好吧，那么请带我了解一下2008年金斯顿电厂发生的事情，当时这座煤灰山破裂了。这股污泥浪潮撞击了一个半岛。它的一半撞击了这个半岛，然后
And almost all of these ponds leak toxins into the groundwater. They are a huge, huge mess. In Kingston, this mountain of coal ash was just a part of the landscape near the power plant. The TVA had covered it with a layer of clay, which allows grasses to grow on top. So to the unfamiliar eye, it could have just looked like a grassy hill. People would do their regular morning runs up and down this mound. Okay, so walk me through what happened at this Kingston plant in 2008 when this mountain of coal ash burst free. This wave of sludge slams into a peninsula. Half it kind of hits this peninsula and it
向右分叉，填满了这条河——埃默里河——的一条深河道。其余的部分撞击了这个半岛，将房屋从地基上撞开。它将鱼抛到河岸上。它撞倒了电线。这几乎就像圣经里的东西。这是在深夜发生的。起初，住在附近的居民以为可能是地震或山体滑坡。整个大地感觉像是在隆隆作响和颤抖。
kind of forks right and fills in this deep channel in this river, the Emory River. And the rest of it slams into this peninsula and knocks homes off their foundation. It hurls fish onto the riverbank. It knocks down power lines. It's almost like something out of the Bible. This was in the middle of the night. At first, people living nearby thought it might be an earthquake or a landslide. The whole earth felt like it was rumbling and trembling.
所以我采访了一位当地人，你知道，他从窗户往外看，看到一股黑色的浪潮正滚过他的院子。其中一栋房子被推离了地基，我想大约有60英尺，并被推向了堤岸，基本上坍塌了。一位女士描述了看着深色的污泥，像湿漉漉的、浓稠的汤一样的污泥，从她的门下涌入，开始填满她的阳光房和客厅，这再次就像恐怖电影里的东西，你知道吗？虽然灾难本身并没有造成重大的人员伤亡，但真正的问题发生在清理过程中。
And so I talked to one local who, you know, he looked out of his window and saw a black wave just rolling across his yard. One home in particular was shoved, I think it was like 60 feet off its foundation and thrust against this embankment and basically collapsed in on itself. One woman describes watching as dark sludge, like wet, soupy sludge, came in under her door and started filling up her sunroom and her living room, which again is like something almost out of like a horror movie, you know? While the disaster itself didn't result in a big loss of life, the real problems took place during the cleanup.
那是2008年。经济处于崩溃边缘。房地产市场和股市刚刚崩盘。TVA从全国各地雇佣了900人来清理这场灾难。所以当这些工会代表开始打电话召集人们来清理时，许多这些蓝领工人很高兴接到这个电话。他们知道这是一场巨大的环境灾难，
It's 2008. The economy is on its knees. The housing market and the stock market have just collapsed. TVA hired 900 people from across the country to come clean up the disaster. So as these union reps start calling to get people to come clean this up, many of these workers, blue collar workers, are delighted to get people to come clean this up. Many of these workers, blue collar workers, are delighted to get this call. They know this is a huge environmental disaster,
但这对他们来说简直是天赐之物。他们不知道的是，这份工作以巨大的健康代价为代价。事实证明，这些工人在整个清理过程中都要求提供呼吸器和防尘口罩，但在大多数情况下并没有得到。所以他们吸入了这种煤灰污泥，而煤灰中含有砷、镭和汞，
but it's kind of a godsend for them. What they didn't know was that this job came at a huge cost to their health. And turns out these workers had asked for respirators and dust masks throughout the cleanup, and in most cases were not given them. And so they had inhaled this coal ash sludge, and coal ash contains arsenic and radium and mercury,
以及你根本不想进入体内的东西。我的意思是，我发现了追溯到1964年的文件，显示TVA一直知道这些东西是有害的、有毒的。我的意思是，这让他们陷入了一个真正的困境，因为每个人都知道这次泄漏非常严重，他们必须清理它，但TVA一直坚持认为污泥
and just stuff you really do not want in your body at all. I mean, I found documents going back to 1964 that show that TVA has known this stuff is hazardous, is toxic. I mean, this puts them in a real conundrum, because everyone knows that this spill was bad enough that they had to clean it up, but TVA kept insisting that the sludge
实际上没有毒。你能描述一下那里发生了什么吗？TVA不想激怒社区。我认为如果工人们在外面穿着全身防化服、戴着防尘口罩和呼吸器走来走去，对社区来说会非常令人不安。所以相反，TVA出来，基本上告诉公众，这些东西不会造成重大的健康风险。
wasn't actually toxic. Could you describe what's going on there? TVA did not want to upset the community. I think it would have been really troubling for the community if the workers were out there stomping around in head-to-toe hazmat suits and dust masks and respirators. So instead, TVA comes out and they basically tell the public, this stuff poses no significant health risk.
基本上，不用担心。他们一遍又一遍地说。这些工人陷入的另一个陷阱是天气极其炎热。所以如果他们穿着全身防化装备，不仅看起来很糟糕，让TVA看起来很糟糕，而且意味着他们必须为工人采取更多的预防措施，因为在95度（华氏度）的天气里穿防化服意味着他们不能工作得那么久或那么努力，而且他们必须提供冷却
Basically, don't worry about it. And they say this over and over and over. Another sort of trap that these workers are in is that it's extremely hot. And so if they were to be in head to toe hazmat gear, not only would it look bad and make TVA look bad, it would mean they'd have to take even more precautions for the workers because wearing a hazmat suit in 95 degree weather means that they can't work as much or as hard and they have to provide cooling
和各种其他东西。是的，完全正确。所以环保署给了TVA非常紧迫的清理期限。如果TVA的分包商雅各布工程公司给工人防尘口罩，是的，他们就需要更多的休息时间。这意味着他们必须离开工作现场，乘坐班车或某种巴士，带他们去休息区，脱掉装备，休息，然后再穿上所有的装备，然后再坐班车回到工作现场。这会减慢整个过程。而且我认为有非常有力的证据表明TVA说，
and all kinds of other stuff. Yes, exactly. So the EPA gave TVA pretty tight deadlines to clean this stuff up. And if Jacob's engineering, the subcontractor in TVA gave the workers dust masks, yes, they would need to take more breaks. And that would mean they would have to leave the job site, get on a shuttle or some kind of bus, take it to a break area, de-robe, take their break, put all their gear back on again, then take a shuttle back to the job site. And it would have slowed the whole process up. And I think there's very compelling evidence that TVA said,
这不能发生。就像是，我们不能在这些防护装备上花费这么多时间，否则我们就无法达到最后期限，如果我们动作慢，环保署就会罚我们几十万甚至几百万美元。一位TVA承包商告诉工人，他们每天吃一磅煤灰都没事。但事情并不好。许多工人在清理工作的头几个月后开始感到不适，
this can't happen. Like this is, we can't take this much time with this protective gear, or we just not going to hit our deadlines and the EPA is going to fine us hundreds of thousands if not millions of dollars if we're slow. One TVA contractor told workers that they could eat a pound of coal ash a day and be fine. But things weren't fine. Many workers started to feel sick after the first few months of cleanup,
但他们将其归咎于过度劳累或睡眠不足。随着时间的推移，情况变得更糟。这些工人开始……他们开始在卡车上倒下，他们开始咳血，然后癌症诊断就来了，你知道，在那之后不久。最终，在当地一位律师的帮助下，数百名工人聚集在一起起诉TVA及其分包商雅各布工程公司，因为他们没有提供适当的防化装备来保护他们的健康。但诉讼过程非常困难，有许多障碍需要克服。最大的问题之一是法官裁定，因为雅各布是代表
but they chalked it up to being overworked or lack of sleep. Things got much worse over time. And these workers start, they start passing on their trucks, they start coughing up blood, then the cancer diagnosis has come, you know, not long after that. Eventually, with the help of a local lawyer, hundreds of these workers gathered together to sue TVA and their subcontractor, Jacobs Engineering, for not giving them the appropriate hazmat gear to protect their health. But the lawsuit proved very difficult, and there were many hurdles to overcome. One of the biggest problems was that a judge ruled that because Jacobs was acting on behalf
TVA行事，所以他们不能被起诉。这是因为TVA虽然像私营公司一样运作，但仍然由联邦政府拥有。这赋予了他们一种叫做“主权豁免”的东西。主权豁免保护TVA和许多其他政府机构免受大量诉讼。
of the TVA, they couldn't be sued. This is because the TVA, even though it operates like a private company, is still owned by the federal government. It grants them something called sovereign immunity. Sovereign immunity protects TVA and many other government agencies from a whole lot of lawsuits.
并非每一项诉讼，但它赋予了他们广泛的保护。我认为最简单的理解方式是，如果政府或其承包商是出于善意行事，比如他们试图遵守法律条文并符合政府的利益，他们就会受到法律的保护。所以在所有这些诉讼之后，
Not every single lawsuit, but it grants them broad protections. I think the simplest way to think about it is if the government or one of his contractors is acting in good faith, like they're trying to follow the letter of the law and acting in the government's interest, they are protected by the law. So after all this litigation,
这一切都围绕着清理人员以及他们是如何接触到这些煤灰的，最终发生了什么？所以在经历了10年残酷的诉讼，案件基本上被驳回了两次，律师在两次上诉中挽救了它，工人们不得不……他们不得不屈服。他们病得太重了，而且他们也
this like all centering around the people that are cleanup crews and how they were exposed to this. Cole Ash, what ended up happening? So after 10 brutal years of litigation where the case gets basically thrown out twice, the lawyers save it on appeal twice, the workers have to, they have to capitulate. They're getting so sick and they're getting
对这10年来悬在他们头上的大问题感到筋疲力尽。我们能拿到钱来支付医疗费吗？最终在2022年，一家联邦上诉法院裁定，雅各布工程公司无权享有授予TVA的主权豁免权，230名工人以7750万美元达成了和解。这相当于每人几十万美元。但有些工人没能活到收到和解金。他们并不满意，但这在这些大型环境侵权案件中经常发生。我在书中谈了很多关于埃克森·瓦尔迪兹号的事情。在
also just exhausted of 10 years of this big question hanging over their heads. Are we going to get any money to cover our medical bills? Eventually in 2022, a federal appeals court ruled that Jacobs Engineering was not entitled to the sovereign immunity granted to the TVA and the 230 workers settled for $77.5 million. That works out to a couple hundred thousand dollars per person. But some workers didn't survive to receive the settlement. They were not pleased, but that's what often happens in these sorts of big environmental tort cases. I talk a lot in my book about Exxon Valdez. There's a lot of parallels between the
埃克森·瓦尔迪兹号案件和我书中写的案件之间有很多相似之处，因为这是同样的剧本。你把事情拖延到人们变得如此绝望，以至于他们不得不或多或少地接受你给他们的任何报价。这就是这些工人身上发生的事情。那么金斯顿煤电厂现在的状况如何？它目前仍在运行。我相信其意图是将其转换为天然气设施。
Exxon Valdez case and the case I write about in my book because it's the same playbook. You drag things out until people get so desperate that they have to more or less take whatever offer you give them. And that's what happened to these workers. So what's the status of the Kingston coal plant now? It is still up and running at this moment. I believe the intent is to convert it into a natural gas facility.
TVA在过去10年里，基本上自从金斯顿灾难以来，一直在逐步淘汰其燃煤电厂，并在这些相同的地点将燃煤电厂转变为建造天然气设施。2015年，政府通过了一套新的法律。这些法律规定TVA必须监测其活跃的煤灰倾倒场，以确保煤灰不会污染地下水。但这里有一个主要的漏洞。美国大多数煤灰场地并没有被积极使用。
TVA over the past 10 years, basically ever since the Kingston disaster, has been gradually phasing out its coal plants and turning its coal plants at these same sites, building natural gas facilities. In 2015, the government passed a new set of laws. These laws mandated that the TVA had to monitor its active coal ash dump sites to make sure that coal ash wasn't contaminating the groundwater. But there's a major loophole here. Most coal ash sites across the US aren't actively used.
全国各地仍然有许多装满煤灰的巨大坑洞，但它们所连接的发电厂并没有运行。这些场地不需要受到监管。是的，所以今年早些时候，拜登总统领导下的环保署终于通过了一项规定，要求电力公司监测其遗留或旧的煤灰池塘，并修复或清理他们发现的任何污染。这个问题在于，电力公司在这些规则下进行自我监管。你可以读我的书，自己判断你是否相信电力公司会诚实地
There are still many giant holes in the ground filled with coal ash across the country, but the power plants they're connected to aren't operating. These sites do not need to be regulated. Yeah, so earlier this year, the EPA under President Biden finally passed a rule that required power companies to monitor their legacy or old coal ash ponds and to remediate or clean up any contamination that they found. The problem with this is that the power companies self-regulate under these rules. You can read my book and judge for yourself whether you trust power companies to be honest
说明他们的煤灰池塘是否污染了地下水。我个人宁愿有环保署的工作人员在现场独立测试这些场地。研究发现，在全国750个煤灰池塘中，几乎所有池塘都污染了地下水。它们每年污染数千英里的美国河流和数百万人的饮用水。我认为很多恶意的人可能会说，好吧，你知道，TVA才是这里真正的问题。
about whether their coal ash ponds are contaminated in groundwater. I for one would rather have EPA people on staff independently testing these sites. Studies have found that of the 750 coal ash ponds across the country, almost all of them contaminate groundwater. They contaminate thousands of miles of American rivers and the drinking water of millions each year. I think a lot of people in bad faith could go, well, you know, the TVA is the real problem here.
但我感觉到你对诋毁TVA有些犹豫，因为它有几十年来代表人民行事的丰富历史，然后才变成了这个造成巨大伤害的企业实体。你能谈谈你对TVA的矛盾心理，以及你希望它的遗产如何呈现给当今世界吗？我不想把TVA彻底摧毁。好吧。有些人想。是的。我不想。我的书对TVA非常批评，因为它多年来犯下了一些可怕的错误。
But I sense some reluctance on your part to vilify the TVA because of its rich history of acting on behalf of people for decades and then becoming this corporate entity that caused a lot of harm. Could you talk about your ambivalence about the TVA and how you want its legacy to be presented to today's world? I do not want to burn TVA to the ground. Okay. Some people do. Yeah. I do not. My book is very critical of TVA because it has made some horrible missteps over the years. made some horrible missteps over the years.
我认为金斯顿发生的事情是一场美国悲剧。金斯顿灾难对该组织来说是一个巨大的污点，但我们需要TVA变得伟大。我们需要他们生产充足的清洁能源，你知道，这样我们才能实现我们的气候目标。这样我们才能继续在这里拥有工业。南方在收入等方面仍然落后于全国其他地区。
And I think what happened at Kingston is an American tragedy. The Kingston disaster was a huge black eye for the organization, but we need TVA to be great. We need them to produce abundant clean power, you know, so we can hit our climate goals. And so we can continue to have industry here. South is still lags the rest of the country in income and whatnot.
我写了一本非常批评TVA的书，希望TVA能够改革，并能重新找回它曾经拥有的罗斯福时代的魔力。好吧，很明显，这些肮脏的煤电厂让人们生病，TVA也知道这一点。那么TVA有没有可能像他们在20世纪60年代和70年代那样尝试核能，但这次没有失败？我只是好奇核能可能实现什么，如果政府当时完全投资于那条道路，我们今天的清洁能源景观会是什么样子。
And I wrote a very critical book of TVA in hopes that TVA can be reformed and can recapture some of the FDR-era magic that it had. Well, it's clear that these dirty coal plants make people sick and TVA knows this. So could there be a way for TVA to try again with nuclear power like they did in the 1960s and 70s, but this time without the failures? Like I'm just curious about what could be possible with nuclear power and how our clean energy landscape would look today if the government had fully invested in that path back then.
我写了一本非常严厉批评田纳西河谷管理局（TVA）的书，希望它能进行改革，重拾罗斯福时代的那种魔力。显而易见，这些肮脏的燃煤电厂让人们生病，而TVA对此心知肚明。那么，TVA有没有可能像上世纪六七十年代那样再次尝试核能，但这次能避免重蹈覆辙呢？我只是很好奇核能还有什么可能性，如果政府当年全力投入那条道路，我们今天的清洁能源格局会是什么样子。
The problem with, okay, I mentioned the seven nuclear power plants that TVA wanted to build. It only completed three of them. But as a result of that, it is billions of dollars in debt, $20 billion in debt, actually. Well it has a, there's a cap on how much debt TVA can take on. It's $30 billion. So it only has $10 billion of wiggle room to build more stuff. Well nuclear power plants cost more than $10 billion. So TVA is in a tight spot right now where it actually is trying to decarbonize because
问题在于，好吧，我提到了田纳西河谷管理局（TVA）原本计划建造的七座核电站。它最终只完成了其中三座。但结果是，它背负了数十亿美元的债务，实际上是200亿美元的债务。嗯，TVA所能承担的债务是有上限的，即300亿美元。所以它只有100亿美元的余地来建设更多项目。然而，核电站的造价超过100亿美元。因此，TVA现在陷入了困境，因为它实际上正试图实现脱碳，因为
I think it sees, because of the Kingston disaster and other such missteps, it knows that coal is not the future. It knows it needs to get off fossil fuels, but it really can't. It is an American tragedy that TVA did not build those seven nuclear power plants. Now this region, the Sun Belt, is exploding in population and we need those nuclear power plants more than ever. Yeah, to me, the sort of the original sin of it is the 1959 act to make it self-sufficient
我认为它看到了，由于金斯顿灾难和其他此类失误，它知道煤炭不是未来。它知道它需要摆脱化石燃料，但它真的做不到。TVA没有建成那七座核电站是一场美国式的悲剧。现在这个地区，即阳光地带，人口正在爆炸式增长，我们比以往任何时候都更需要那些核电站。是的，对我来说，这其中的原罪是1959年的法案，要求它实现自给自足
and act like a corporation. I mean, I firmly believe that anyone who believes that the government should be run like a business doesn't know anything about government or business. You know, like that's not how things work. That's totally my view. We have to hope that lawmakers outside the Tennessee Valley nudge it in the right direction. Yeah. Well, what it needs to, I mean, to me,
并像一家公司一样运作。我的意思是，我坚信任何认为政府应该像企业一样经营的人，对政府或商业一无所知。你知道，事情根本不是那样运作的。这完全是我的观点。我们必须希望田纳西河谷以外的立法者能推动它朝着正确的方向发展。是的。嗯，它需要做的，我的意思是，对我来说，
what it needs to do to work is it needs to be run the way it was designed to run, which is a socialist organization. Like, I mean, that's really, it's the source of the conundrum, is that it is a thing designed to do a thing that is not allowed to do that thing it was designed to do.
它要发挥作用需要做的是，它需要按照它被设计的方式来运作，即作为一个社会主义组织。我的意思是，这确实是困境的根源，它是一个被设计用来做某事的东西，却不被允许做它被设计用来做的那件事。
Exactly. I'm kind of like a classic New Deal Democrat. And so I actually have a TVA electricity for all baseball cap that I wear. So can I wear this with pride? Like do you, when you think of like, what does TVA mean to you and would it be okay for a progressive like me to wear a TVA hat? TVA was born of such noble intentions,
没错。我有点像那种经典的新政民主党人。所以我实际上有一顶写着“TVA电力惠及全民”的棒球帽，我会戴着它。那么我可以自豪地戴着它吗？比如，当你想到TVA对你意味着什么时，像我这样的进步派戴着TVA的帽子可以吗？TVA诞生于如此崇高的意图，
but all of the rest of the stuff that comes after World War II is, that's the messy part. As much as I am rooting for TVA, I would not wear a TVA hat. The day TVA finishes its seven nuclear power plants, I'll probably wear a TVA hat again. Yeah, yeah.
但二战之后发生的所有其他事情，那才是混乱的部分。尽管我支持TVA，但我不会戴TVA的帽子。等TVA建成那七座核电站的那一天，我可能会再戴上TVA的帽子。是的，是的。
Jared, thank you so much for the book. I loved reading it and thank you so much for talking with us. It's been a real pleasure. Thank you for having me. This was such a treat. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Lash Madon, edited by Nina Potuck, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Riau. Special thanks this week to Jared Sullivan, author of Valley So Low, One Lawyer's Fight
贾里德，非常感谢你的书。我读得很开心，也非常感谢你与我们交谈。这真是一次愉快的经历。谢谢你邀请我。这真是一种享受。《99%隐形》本周由Lash Madon制作，Nina Potuck编辑，Martin Gonzalez混音，Swan Riau配乐。本周特别感谢《低谷：一位律师在全美重大煤炭灾难后的正义之战》一书的作者贾里德·沙利文
for Justice in the Wake of America's Great Coal great coal catastrophe. It is a really good fun read. If you like those John Grissom style like legal thrillers, this is right up your alley. Kathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barrupe, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
这是一本非常有趣的好书。如果你喜欢约翰·格里森风格的法律惊悚小说，这本书非常适合你。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁佩、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·雷、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora Building, in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites. We're spending much more time on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to the Discord server as Oakland, California. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们现在是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们。我们在Blue Sky以及我们自己的Discord服务器上花费了更多时间。Discord服务器有一个链接，就在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。